meaning fulfillment a lot of people want
that in life everyone wants that in life
but how do we attain what is meaningful
or what is fulfilling it's a very tough
question and it doesn't have one answer
but what I can say is that the opposite
feeling of meaning and fulfillment is
what we call nihilism
we're birthed from the Stars we are
lucky and fortunate to be living on this
earth nihilism says whatever doesn't
matter it's all meaningless the other
take is that there is a lot of meaning
that we can make our own meaning that we
can have some sort of fulfillment in
life from being birthed by the Stars
onto this planet so
I like to think about that one because
my souls just pulled between the two all
the time
so when I think about the latter where
there is some sort of meeting and that
it's up to us to make a meaningful life
overtime I like to think about things
like you know visiting the Italian
Riviera here in La Spezia but I also
like to think about things like building
things of value into the world and
bringing myself fulfillment through
bringing something of utility to the
planet as our ancestors have done in the
past that's why we have boats and why we
have houses and why we have lights into
the internet everything that we use
today is because our ancestors have
built that for us so just like that it's
up to us to build what these next most
fundamental tools and utilities are for
the future generations
what are those how do they bring us
meaning and fulfillment it's all very
challenging to answer but finding
meaning and fulfillment is something
that I love and something that I
struggle with something that so many of
us struggle with and we're gonna be
talking about this quite a bit at the
upcoming event that we're hosting with
Jason Silva August 23rd make sure you've
got your tickets for that in San
Francisco and the mental health epidemic
that also accompanies that how much of
that actually has to do with fame
fortune greed social media
all of these sort of new aspects to
mainstream media and culture that can be
affecting the way that we perceive
ourselves and that we don't perceive
ourselves at this pinnacle and that
causes a lot of anxiety and grief that
after so anyway we'll be talking about
this in a lot more soon coming in to
chat about meeting to chat about
fulfillment thanks for tuning in just
like you know formulating our dualistic
perspective about nihilism and meaning
together and seeing exactly where that
takes us in the future much love
everyone thanks for tuning in italian
riviera last busier